[Music]
Straight Ahead online crime daily
the Parkland school shooter penalty
phase trial the rebuttal case begins
with some damning evidence what is that
design on the boot if I didn't ask you
that before
that's a swastika and week three begins
in the Sandy Hook defamation trial
people saying this must be fake he's an
actor he's smiling out oh you're out of
character all those things The Proven
testimony given by a shooting victim's
father plus an unexpected early release
in the Pike County Massacre trial out of
Ohio with the Unexplained of German
could mean and later the North Dakota
love triangle trial of Nikki Sue Ensel
the last time anyone saw Chad and soul
alive was leaving Bowling on December
30th 2019 and approximately 10 30 PM
prosecutors present their opening
statement after the feminist tried in
connection with her husband's murder
lawn crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to Long crime daily I'm
your host Brian buckmeyer jurors are
back in court for the first time in more
than a week as the prosecution begins
its rebuttal case and the Parkland
school shooter penalty phase trial on
February 14th of 2018 a then 19 year old
gunman opened fire at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School 17 people were
killed and 17 more injured in October of
last year the gunman pled guilty to all
charges he now faces a sentence of life
in prison or the death penalty on
Tuesday the prosecution began its
rebuttal case in the penalty phase trial
this comes nearly two weeks after the
defense abruptly rested its case causing
judge Elizabeth schreer to call the move
unprofessional and uncalled for in the
days leading up to the rebuttal case the
judge ruled in favor of the prosecution
allowing the state to show jurors
swastikas drawn on the defendant's boots
and AR-15 on Tuesday a Broward County
detective took the stand virtually
explaining he met with the defendant at
the hospital on the day of the shooting
and collected items for evidence
you came into contact with Nicholas Cruz
I did and did you have occasion to take
his shoes
yes I did and what kind of shoes were
they
their boots they're black
um boots this is one of my photographs
and this is uh one of the boots that I
uh collected on that day from Cruz
and does this picture 26 Jay trillion
accurately depict the boot that you took
from the defendant
yes there's only one swastika there's
not no nothing on the second boot
correct
on the left boot no I went through them
pretty thoroughly is this the same
swastika just a close-up picture
yes it is okay the same Boot and
um what is it what is that design on the
boot if I didn't ask you that before
that's a swastika
I'm joining us today as legal analyst
analyst captain lozardo and co-host
Terry Austin Catherine did the
prosecution start off strong in the
rebuttal case if so with what
I think they did as we saw they started
off by actually admitting the AR-15 gun
physically admitting it as evidence and
also the magazine and the boots with the
swastika symbol on there those are very
important because we've been seeing how
in the defense side they've been
humanizing uh Nicholas Cruz and we've
forgotten about all of these physical
evidence but by starting off by showing
how big an ominous that AR-15 is that
brings that back that memory back into
the jury's mind now just because those
the swastika and AR-15 could be
prejudicial to Nicholas Cruz doesn't
necessarily mean that it's inadmissible
or violates his due process the Florida
Supreme Court actually has had a
separate case that allowed swastika to
be admitted into evidence under
circumstance circumstances that are more
heinous than this I'm absolutely now
Terry after the prosecution's rebuttal I
know we're looking ahead a little far
what happens next in the trial well you
know you're right Brian it is coming to
an end after both sides rest I expect
that we'll see motions we'll see renewed
motions I definitely think the defense
is going to make a renewed motion for a
mistrial because we've seen that happen
several times and then I think obviously
they're going to try to finalize those
jury instructions and of course we'll
have to see closing arguments and
deliberation but deliberation is only
going to be about the damages as we know
because he's already pled guilty to all
of this heinous Massacre so we'll see
what happens after all of this but
they'll go straight to deliberations and
see how much you know comes out whether
he's going for life or death of course
again this is not about a question of
Innocence or guilt again as Terry said
it's about life or death
still had on Law and crime daily we
turned to Ohio as George Wagner IV
stands trial for his part in the Pike
County Massacre but first the Sandy Hook
defamation trial out of Connecticut
victim Dylan hockley's father takes the
stand to describe the Fallout of the
deadly shooting
[Music]
welcome back as week three begins in the
Alex Jones defamation trial out of
Connecticut jurors hear emotional
testimony from the father of a Sandy
Hook school shooting victim last month
Jones was ordered to pay more than 49
million dollars in Damages as part of a
separate defamation case out of Texas
Jones could soon owe even more in
Damages as part of another defamation
suit out of Connecticut 15 plaintiff Sue
Jones after he claimed the Sandy Hook
school shooting was a hoax put on by
actors Jones has already been found
liable for damages in this case meaning
jurors will now decide how much Jones
should pay on Tuesday Ian Hockley father
of victim Dylan Hockley took the stand
he told you as his family was forced to
take down a YouTube video of his son's
Memorial after it was bombarded with
hateful comments about the shooting
being a hoax later he explained how he
reacts 10 years after the shooting when
people continue to call him an actor
in what way or ways if any has the uh
The Narrative of you being an actor
faking your child's death or some other
purposes of of your of deal and never
having lived affect your uh the way you
go about that
I'm very intentional to make sure that
story is there and and I will warn the
audience that we will be talking about
the events of 12 14 because I want to
establish my truth and my journey so I'm
very definite I'm doing that but I'm
also aware
that that could draw out someone who's
there who wants to stop me you know
attack me and just I'm just constantly
aware that that's a thing but I'm in
weighing those two out this wins out
that I'm going to tell this story I'm
going to share about Dylan and so I just
have to be careful I just have to be
careful about where I go and speak who I
go to
New York Times writer and author of the
book Sandy Hook an American Tragedy and
the Battle For Truth Elizabeth
Williamson has been inside the courtroom
she explains the impact she's noticed as
Alex Jones hasn't been there
I can tell you what the families are
thinking and and what they've expressed
in the past in the first damages trial
earlier this Summer that this is an act
of cowardice not to turn up uh in the
courtroom but rather to hold forth
outside where he can control the floor
not submit once again you know jurors
after the first damages trial were
saying that not only did they find that
it was an act of cowardice not to turn
up and face these families except when
he's compelled to testify or chooses to
testify
but really it's it's kind of a um it
shows disregard for the judicial process
in general and you know you have to
remember of course that the jurors are
here because they believe in the court
process and they believe in the judicial
system so for them to be here and have
him not show up except to deliver this
sort of tirade that he did last Thursday
I think reflects very negatively on him
I would agree as well powerful words
Terry emotional and heartbreaking
testimony but does that how does that
translate to how much drones will have
to pay these families you know I do
think that it will affect the jury no
doubt about it when you have emotional
testimony like that the jury is feeling
it they're putting themselves in the
place of these parents and they
absolutely are going to feel as though
they need to award a large number we saw
that in Texas a large number was awarded
I think because there are more families
here we might see a larger number and
the fact that Alex Jones himself
expresses No Remorse he doesn't respect
the system and I think the jury sees
that too they are here and they are
doing their Duty and the least he can do
is to come to court so I think the
emotional testimony the fact that Alex
Jones is disregarding the system all
that is going to weigh heavily on the
jury and I think we're going to come
back with a large award yeah Catherine
Terry and Elizabeth Williamson I think
are kind of touching the issue slightly
so let's get right to it Ian hockley's
testimony compared to that of Alex Jones
on the stand last week the comparison
has got to look devastating for Jones
right
definitely in terms of last week we saw
Jones testify in what looked like a
circus trial because he was so
uncontrollable by both the judge and his
own lawyer and also the the plaintiff's
lawyer everyone were having a hard time
trying to control him and what his
testimony would be as compared to uh
Dylan's father today who was so
emotional and you really feel the
damages that has happened to this family
his testimony is helpful with the damage
inside even showing that after all of
these years he's still feeling that pain
and suffering that no father should feel
absolutely really a contrast makes it
look one good and one bad it's not
something you want for the defense
attorney here well also in Celebrity
legal news the Santa Fe County district
attorney says actor Alec Baldwin and
three others could still face charges in
the deadly Rush shooting in October of
last year Bolton was holding a prop
weapon on the set of the western movie
The Gun went off and Cinema photographer
Helena Hutchins and director Joel Souza
were shot Hutchins died as a result of
her injuries while Baldwin maintains he
never pulled the trigger nearly one year
later no criminal Charities have been
filed in relation to the shooting but
Santa Fe officials say they could soon
be on the way this comes as the District
Attorney's Office made an emergency
funding request of more than six hundred
thousand dollars to continue the
investigation prosecutors say they have
not yet determined if charges are
warranted but say this could be a
homicide case a final report of the
deadly shooting has not yet been
released by the Sheriff's Office
coming up on Law and Prime daily opening
statements are presented in the love
triangle murder case out of North Dakota
plus the Pike County Massacre Court
abruptly ends early on day 12 of George
Wagner IV's truck
[Music]
welcome back the Ohio trial of George
Wagner IV unexpectedly ends early as he
faces murder charges for his part in the
2016 Pike County Massacre George along
with his brother Edward Jake Wagner and
their parents Angela and Billy are all
accused of having a part in the
execution-style murders of the Rhoden
and Gilly families back in April of
2016. all eight victims were found shot
to death most in their beds as they
slept initially officials thought the
murders could be drug related but later
determined the killings allegedly
stemmed from a custody dispute involving
a child Jake shared with Hannah Rhoden
Jake and Angela both pled guilty in the
case they are expected to testify
against George a key piece of evidence
in the case were shoe Impressions found
on the crime scenes investigators say
Angela Wagner admitted to buying shoes
from Walmart for Jake and George the
actual shoes were never found on Tuesday
just as another BCI agent took the stand
to testify about those shoes the court
recess unexpectedly without any
explanation testimony is set to resume
Wednesday morning
Terry quarter adjourned early but there
was no reason given as to why what
should we take away from that
well you know Brian there could be a
number of reasons for that early
adjournment as you said the shoe expert
did not want to take the stand did not
want to go before the camera but
apparently she did testify just not
before the camera and before her the
other witness he also talked about
physical evidence he talked about the
guns and all of the casings that were
found in the various incidents that
happen on all of those four locations so
you know he talked about the rifle there
was a handgun there was a Glock and then
afterwards at some point council did say
they wanted to go through the evidence
and I'm thinking that perhaps because
there is so much evidence that they
needed to sort out perhaps the judge
gave them a little more time to do that
so that when the jury does come back
tomorrow they'll have it all sorted out
and he would not have wasted the jury's
time so it could have been something as
simple as that yeah maybe there's a lot
of evidence they just want to admit in
quickly and we'll see a lot of that as
you say tomorrow or Wednesday morning
sorry well Catherine there are many
victims in the crime scene so
prosecutors are focusing on one scene at
a time is that the right approach here
I think it is because the prosecution
says that they will present their
evidence in order because of the fact
that there are so many victims here
eight victims of the fam Road and family
were executed like you said mostly in
their sleep and three of the locations
were in Union Hill Road and one location
in the left Fork Road for the jury to
compartmentalize and really visualize
what each murder happened is very
important especially since they visited
the site beforehand yeah it makes it a
lot easier to digest in those small
organized bites as they're doing there
well when we come back we head to North
Dakota for the trial of Nikki Sue Ensel
opening statements are presented as Enzo
stands trial in connection to her
husband's murder
foreign
[Music]
daily we head to North Dakota where
prosecutors present their opening
statement in the love triangle of Nikki
Sue Ensel as she strived for allegedly
conspiring to kill her husband
investigators allege Ensel was having an
affair with a man named Earl Howard
while she was still married to her
husband Chad in late December of 2019
officials believe ensl and Howard
conspired to kill Chad for a life
insurance pail and just days after
filing a 26 thousand dollar property
insurance policy on the home Ensel
shared with her husband investigators
believe on December 31st Ensel and
Howard shot and killed Chad in their
master bedroom with a shotgun Days Later
firefighters and police responded to
Enzo calling 9-1-1 about a fire at the
home investigators believe the two
started the firing to cover up the
murder police couldn't determine if it
was ensl or Howard who pulled the
trigger they are both charged with
conspiracy to commit murder among other
charges Howard pled guilty to conspiracy
and arson charges and was sentenced to
25 years prosecutors on Tuesday gave a
timeline of what they say happened in
the days leading up to Chad's death
while Chad was at his bowling bowling
league on Monday that's when they went
to the house between 7 and 8 30 p.m so
that they could collect property of
Nikki's after that there's no more
security video at the house because it
was turned into privacy vote while they
were there between that 7 and 8 30 pm
time frame
they grabbed the propane heater from the
garage and put it in the house they
grabbed a shotgun from the bedroom and
they put that somewhere in the house
they got the shells for the shotgun and
they loaded the shotgun
and they left they came back to the
house on December 31st 2019 at
approximately one o'clock in the morning
between 1 and 3 A.M on December 31st
2019
Chad Ansel was shot twice with a shotgun
and left dead in the home before they
left the residence after Chad was shot
they staged the room
they staged the bedroom to make it look
like Chad killed himself
the defense didn't present their opening
statement Tuesday but instead deferred
it until after the state presents its
case
Catherine how is the prosecution's
opening did they open with an airtight
case
I'm not sure about airtight but they did
present a very good opening statement
there I say that because it's so easy to
understand what what the prosecution was
saying as to the the facts the details
and what Nikki did and her this love
triangle they also presented how the why
they she took out an insurance policy
before Chad died and also that there's a
love affair with this other guy so that
that's why he he uh she murdered uh Chad
but we don't know who actually pulled
the trigger and that's the issue what's
fascinating is the prosecution actually
charged her with conspiracy so it
doesn't really matter who pulled the
trigger I believe as long as they can
prove that Nikki and her co-conspirators
were the ones who uh agreed to murder
Chad that's enough yeah but Terry
thinking about the defense what if they
just Blame Howard for everything could
that get Ensel off on a not guilty
you know what Brian I think that's not
going to happen I mean anything is
possible but I seriously doubt she'll
get an acquittal she was charged as
Catherine said with conspiracy to commit
murder conspiracy to commit arson and
conspiracy to tamper with evidence so
for all of that you just need that plan
and that agreement and even if somehow
she convinces that jury that he did pull
the trigger the boyfriend Howard they're
still going to understand and know she
was the one who took out that she was
the one who was in the home the fire was
set and she is in this love triangle and
it is her motive that started this
entire string of events so I think even
if they blame it on Howard
we're going to get guilty at least on
one of those charts I'll be interested
to see what the defense says as they
postpone that opening statement
Catherine Terry thank you very much and
thank you for joining us here on Law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
discuss Justice in America
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]